ABOUT BOB MEN MHEN
ABOUT BOB MEN MENN
ABOUT BOB MEN MENENDEZ HE
WOULD NEVER CONSIDER HIRING
SOMEONE ON THE BASIS OF
RELEVANT QUALIFICATIONS.
RECENTLY WE TOLD YOU ON THIS
PROGRAM ABOUT THE WAVE OF
ITEM CRAWSK CHANGE
DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGE.
IT WAS LESS THAN 2%
HISPANIC.
TODAY THANKS TO MASS
IMMIGRATION, HAZLETON IS
MAJORITY HISPANIC.
MORE THAN HALF OF THE
RESIDENTS THERE SPEAK A
LANGUAGE OTHER THAN ENGLISH
AT HOME.
WE GOT THOSE NUMBERS FROM A
RECENT PIECE IN NATIONAL
GEOGRAPHIC WHICH QUOTED
LIFELONG HAZLETON RESIDENTS
SAYING THEY NO LOCKER
RECOGNIZE THEIR OWN
HOMETOWN.
THEY DIDN'T HATE IMMIGRANTS.
MOST AMERICANS LIKE
IMMIGRANTS.
BUT THIS WAS TOO MUCH CHANGE
AND FEWER THAN 20 YEARS THE
CULTURE THEIR PARENTS AND
GRANDPARENTS HAD BUILT
EVAPORATED.
THEY NEVER ASKED FOR ANY OF
THAT IT WAS JUST IMPOSED ON
THEM.
THEY WERE BEWILDERED, UNDER
STANDABLY.
NOT EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS OR
EVEN CARESS.
THIS MORNING CNN RAN A HIT
PIECE ON THAT SEGMENT,
WRITER RON BROWNSTEIN
DESCRIBED IT AS
EXTRAORDINARY SCREED AGAINST
DIVERSITY WHAT ABOUT THAT
MEANS.
HE SUGGESTED WE WERE BIGOTS
FOR TALKING ABOUT THE
SUBJECT AT ALL.
THIS, OF COURSE, IS HOW YOU
BULLY PEOPLE INTO BEING
QUIET WHILE YOU PERMANENTLY
CHANGE THEIR COUNTRY AND
USUALLY IT WORKS.
BECAUSE NOBODY WANTS THE
HEADACHE OF THAT.
BUT, IN THIS CASE, IT'S AN
IMPORTANT ENOUGH TOPIC THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GO A LITTLE
DEEPER ON IT WHAT HAPPENED
WHEN HAZLETON IS HAPPENING
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
NEIGHBORHOODS TRANSFORMED
FOREVER WITH NO PUBLIC
DEBATE.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS WHERE
THIS IS NOT HAPPENING.
IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE
THE PEOPLE WHO MAKE THESE
DECISIONS LIVE.
HERE'S SOME NUMBERS.
IN STORM-LAKE IOWA ONLY A
TINY PERCENTAGE OF THE
POPULATION FOREIGN BORN JUST
25 YEARS AGO.
NOW MORE THAN HALF OF ALL
RESIDENTS STORM LAKE DON'T
SPEAK ENGLISH AT HOME.
AMTRAK, MICHIGAN HAD TWO
BANGLADESHI RESIDENTS IN
1990, TODAY THAT CITY IS
MAJORITY MUSLIM.
FEWER THAN 40% OF THE PEOPLE
WHO SPEAK THERE SPEAK
ENGLISH AT HOME.
CNN PIECE RON BROWNSTEIN
SUGGEST THIS WHOLE
CONVERSATION IS ABOUT WHITE
FEAR.
LIBERALS OFTEN SAY THAT
ALMOST ALWAYS THEY SAY THAT
BECAUSE TO HIDE THE TRUTH OF
IT WHICH IS THAT THE
STARKEST EFFECTS OF MASS
IMMIGRATION DON'T TAKE PLACE
IN WHITE NEIGHBORHOODS.
THEY TAKE PLACE WHERE NATIVE
BORN AFRICAN-AMERICANS LIVE.
FOR EXAMPLE, NOT SO LONG AGO
COMPTON, CALIFORNIA, THE
FAMOUS COMPTON WAS THE
LARGEST BLACK COMMUNITY WEST
OF THE MISSISSIPPI.
TODAY ONLY A THIRD OF
COMPTON'S POPULATION IS
AFRICAN-AMERICAN.
THE REST IS HISPANIC.
THAT'S HUGE CHANGE.
THAT'S MASSIVE DISLOCATION.
NOBODY TALKS ABOUT IT.
PEOPLE LIKE RON BROWNSTEIN
SHOUT THEM INTO SILENCE BUT
IT'S REAL AND FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO USED TO LIVE
THERE, IT'S TRAUMATIC.
NOW LET'S CONSIDER HOW THE
OTHER HALF LIVES.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE MAKING
THESE DECISIONS ABOUT
IMMIGRATION AND DEMOGRAPHIC
CHANGE.